hey what's up my name's samuel leeds
welcome back to my channel and this week
has been an incredible week the sun has
been shining brightly
i'm feeling in a really good mood i've
even got a little bit of a suntan
so i thought i would go through some
very advanced training with you on this
video
i'm gonna be going through the six
things the six
steps that you need to do to start
in property and then to scale your
property business
and ultimately to win and succeed big so
as i go through these six steps i'm also
going to be giving you some actionable
steps some practical information
this video could potentially sound
really extreme but it could potentially
change
your life but only if you take
action i'm also going to be giving you
some opportunities some giveaways some
links and some resources as we go
throughout this video
so my suggestion would be to do a few
things before you begin watching this
video
number one is to sit yourself in a quiet
spot where you can focus with good wi-fi
number two maybe get a pen and paper or
even get your phone out or another
device you can take
notes as we go along and number three
before you start watching
please do smash the like button
also don't forget to subscribe turn on
the notification bell
because it's the winners are the people
that actually educate yourself
in fact that's the first step to educate
yourself now the fact that you're
watching this youtube video
is amazing most people aren't i mean
this video might have a few thousand
people watching but
a a youtube video with a the latest
music
chart video with women dancing and
people drinking and
that will get millions of views but the
people that can actually succeed and win
in life and be completely financially
free
are always the people that first educate
themselves
so massive respect to you just for
watching this video
for liking the video for sharing it for
subscribing to the channel
if you want to really educate yourself
well let me tell you a story there was a
a man who had to chop a tree down and he
only had a day
to chop the tree down one day he had to
chop this tree down he was given a saw
and halfway through the day someone came
up to him and said
why haven't you even started yet you've
only got a day and you've not even
started trying to chop the tree down and
he was a very wise man and he said it's
because right now
i am sharpening the ax i'm sharpening
the saw
i'm going to spend three quarters of the
day
sharpening the saw and then
chopping down the tree is going to be
really easy and in the same way
a lot of people that want to succeed in
business they do nothing because they
haven't got the knowledge they haven't
educated themselves or they
go out and have a bash but they haven't
got the right training and the right
tools so if you want to really sharpen
your skills
sharpen your tools then i'd like to
invite you this is my first resource of
the video
i'd like to invite you to be mentored by
me
to be mentored by me and our certified
panel of mentors where you can have
architects you can have experts in deal
sources rent to rents
that can answer your questions and help
you to join the mastermind program every
week we have a mastermind program
now look you can join this for one
pound and me and my team will personally
mentor you
it's a pound for seven days and then
it's 95 pounds a month
and you can cancel within the seven day
trial do it
okay i don't make any profit from this
it's small money
i have to put a lot of money into the re
resourcing this thing
but i know that it will change your life
so that's the very first step is
education educate yourself i will leave
a link in the description to samuel 365.
step two there's six steps step two is
to do something called co-deal sourcing
now your sourcing is simply when you
find a property investment that's good
and then you
pass it to a deal sourcing company
a deal sourcing company will then take
your deal from you willingly
and they will sell your deal to an
investor
and they will give you a fee
you don't have to have a business they
can pay you the fee to your personal
bank
you don't have to be compliant you don't
have to have insurance because
you aren't selling the deal the company
is selling the deal
what you're doing is you're finding the
deal and passing it to the company
and taking your percentage of the
finder's fee
this will typically generate you between
500 pounds and a thousand pounds per
time you do it
and anyone can do this you just have to
know
or who are the companies let me tell you
something there's
hundreds of companies and that's why i
suggest that you join samuel 365 because
not only will you get the
education to sharpen your skills but
you'll also
get the access to the team and meet
these people so that's number two
coding or source step two step number
three is deal source yourself
set up your own deal sourcing company
and package deals and sell them to
investors
this is the fastest way to get quick
money in your bank now i'm not talking
about getting rich quick
but i am talking about getting results
quick and when you package and sell
deals
when you start getting money in your
bank even it might only be two grand or
three grand or four grand
here and there your confidence will go
up and with that money what are you
going to do with it you're going to
reinvest it
back into your business back into your
education
back into your property portfolio
yourself
so education
deal sourcing number four point
venture with other investors this is
just the most amazing thing ever
and what do i mean by joint venture what
i mean is
you can when you're finding property
deals that are good instead of selling
them all the time and just getting a
quick bit of money
once you're getting good at finding
deals and once you've got a little bit
of an investor list
you can find deals and say to your
investors
hey instead of you buying the deal off
me how would anybody feel about
investing in the deal you
find the deal you negotiate the deal
with your skills that you've learned
through samuel 365 which is our
mentoring training platform
but then you say you put the money in
i found the deal and we'll go 50 50
on the profits you've only got to do
this twice and then
you've got basically a 100 of one free
house
i would rather have 50 of something than
100 of nothing
and most people go around their whole
lives trying to save up
trying to build their portfolio wishing
it would happen dreaming it would happen
but it never happens whereas when you
learn to bring in joint venture partners
it can start happening real fast so
joint venture really important although
i do have a training course on joint
ventures
i also have a training course on deal
setting i'll leave all the links in the
description
below for you to actually get started
and do this
number five once you started building
your portfolio
got a bit of cash from deal sourcing i
talked to about scale
scalability how to get started in
business how to scale your business and
succeed in business
in the property industry so number five
is to
learn the skill of buy refurbished
refinance rent this is the
brr strategy when you can learn to find
properties cheap where you can push the
value up and then refinance
it means that instead of taking 50 grand
even if it's someone else's money let's
say
a joint venture partner says i'll put 50
grand into a deal with you you take the
50 grand you put it into a deal
the 50 grand is locked in the deal so
what you want to do is you want to take
the 50 grand put it into a deal
but then push the value of the house up
refinance based on the new value
and pull the 50 grand out and then what
are you going to do with it do it again
again again again again on brr
properties where you can learn to find
these types of properties
and find these types of investors it's a
game changer so
again i'll leave a course in the
description of
samuel 365 of the different training
options that we have available
before going on to step number six step
number six is
once you've become financially
independent once you've got a few
properties
once you know how to deal source you
build your investors you build your
properties
get in good cash i would recommend doing
what i did
and getting into property development
property development
you can get paid six figures sometimes
even seven
figure profits on one
deal so when you become financially free
i would start looking for
bigger and bigger deals because a big
deal on a small deal
take just as much energy i'm running a
whole course on this called
property development secrets intensive
and guess what it's a one
pound course let me tell you something
the reason i have so many students you
see on winners on a wednesday people
winning and becoming financially free
because of me and my training
is because not only do i offer the best
training on the planet when it comes to
property investment
but it's also ridiculously cheap
most of my training is either free or
really affordable
like 95 pound a month so property
development that's where you're going to
really start making big
big money so i hope you found this short
video helpful
as i say i hope you've taken good notes
i hope you smash the like button and
share this video around
and don't forget look through the
description you can see the different
options different courses
you can see the mentorship program if
you want to request a training advisor
to give you a call and talk about how to
best jump on some of the training
programs i'll leave a link as well where
you can book a call which
it costs nothing where you can chat with
one of our training advisors
and talk about what package is the best
for you i'll leave that in the
description
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe to my channel where you can
see
a video every single day where i'm going
to be where i interview
students i show you around my projects i
show you around my students projects
i talk about what's going on in the news
the property market news i give
predictions
so subscribe so you don't miss a future
video and i look forward to seeing you
next time